high-five wait high-five wait uh hey you
want to go you want to go they're making
Rock'em Sock'em robots now I don't like
your mom's face I've never seen your
mom's face this is this is getting good
so anyway subscribe to the sub teams the
hump asaurus rex coming at you got my
homegirl Livia here with me to check out
some new trailers how's it going I'm
good I'm excited really bad I would want
to console you and probably stop this
video so that we could talk it out get
to the core of what's going on and
really on yeah I'm what am I talking
about guys Kingdom Hearts 3 is coming
out finally maybe if they stick to this
hopefully one would hope I mean I I
played the original Kingdom Hearts way
back in the day it's been a long time I
remember being really jacked about The
Nightmare Before Christmas land because
I love that movie that's my experience
at this game 85 85 I remember loving it
so I'm looking forward to this hopefully
it lives up to wanting to yeah we're
gonna watch two trailers in fact we're
gonna do them one after the other so
we're gonna start with the square Enix
III showcase trailer and then we're
gonna move right on to the frozen
trailer cuz cuz everybody loves those
sisters those know especially for like
25 minutes in front of Coco that's my
favorite way to let it go that's from
the frozen alright let's hop into this
business right now hit and play this is
the showcase trailer okay I will go
visit for that rating information
up
it's very hard to run in that really low
for these are friends you know never met
him
don't know anyone blue green or white
[Music]
it's amazing
she's decimated the trainees controlling
no all I ever do was this apartment
[Music]
give me
whoa
[Music]
whoa
Oh that'll be Tanglewood
[Music]
still Sora that doesn't mean you should
change except the power you're given
find the hearts joined oh yeah
oh I remember those guys for darkness I
know I wanna do
Roxas does exist these heart inside my
heart in what a style things nothing who
would please us more than boxes is
returned Roxas
yes for the virtual world to be
completely realized
Ansem the wise would have included Roxas
is full data in the construction
[Music]
Nikki you're too late oh no Mickey what
am i missed if this is a problem Mickey
can't solve I mean miss Kasich yeah
Mickey don't look so anything departs
Dubrow oh is that is am I missing a big
context clue right now Miguel Raton
gettin gettin a little mischievous you
know we gotta accept that as as happy
and carefree as Mickey is I mean he's
probably made just as many mistakes as
the rest of us man
well guys this video just got a lot more
interesting originally we were going to
do two trailers but then we discovered
the frozen trailer that we found was
actually the same trailer so we thought
we're only gonna do one trailer but then
they dropped this pirates trailer and
yeah and you know who could pass up a
chance to see what Kingdom Hearts does
with pirates so you're still gonna get
two reactions for the price of none
let's check this thing out let's do it I
gotta put my bad continuity one two
three there's that quote again yo ho yo
ho a pirate's life for me
cuz we get to be pirates again yep
you always did like this world still
it's good but it's a real shame we don't
have a bigger ship
[Music]
dang
[Music]
like
whoa
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
okay okay that's a cool creature you
back in the organization yes surprising
isn't it Jack don't you give this creep
the time of day Sora Xander it's the
kind not I strike a virus aboard ship
when said pirate offers shall have it
I'm looking for a box then the Unversed
collected enough screams and sadness
from those children you're following her
maybe she's one of the seven pure lights
Inari and at the end they'll finally
realize what destiny has in store for
you in fact your reward might be right
around the corner
hey axel
[Music]
Hey liking there we go that's your
context
[Music]
what a strange ending
hey man hearts are throbbing
very romantic coda to that trailer no
that's what this is really all about
it's the fight for love
yes what Sora's really doing this for
but what are those things called with
the glowy eyes yeah there you go
how could you be so heartless don't
worry the next there's gonna be another
trailer with a different world and then
we're gonna hear it when they go into
Tron we're gonna hear that you know
right you know what I was hoping when I
saw parts of the Caribbean I really
didn't like it in kingdom hearts - I
thought it was garbage the graphics were
awful and Sora and Micky they looked out
of place yeah it looks really good here
actually I wish they were doing Treasure
Planet or Landis you'd be like that but
it looks much better than peanut Mart
students or just looks so happy I know
right Sora's a good kid he's got a heart
of gold I've always had a bit of a clash
when it comes to the designs like it's
cool to see a more photorealistic Sora
and those characters crashed into these
but especially when you get to like just
humans it starts to become a little
tricky for my mind to kind of melt the
two together but they're rendered really
well I mean that whole cast looked like
all these actors I wonder I gotta
imagine somebody subbed the voice for
Johnny Depp Kingdom white it's kind of
weirding out at the Hat like he's
immortalizes Jack Sparrow forever no
matter what's going on with him and you
know everything everything else it looks
much better than Kingdom Hearts - okay
oh yeah yeah well is I think between the
two of them it is actually kind of cool
that they seem to be coming in on these
movies like mid sequence like you come
in halfway through a scene that whole
ship cresting the dunes that's from part
three right when the ship goes up over
the sand
in there 25 Jack thanks thanks jeez damn
Merle fact-checking over here the car I
guess he must intercept Elsa like
partway through that movie when she
first flips out and runs away yeah we
must be joining her mid film inhave if
Sora and the gang are able to help her
out it that'll really change the con new
hire these games cannons the children
who love frozen may very well be playing
it now that this you can manipulate nice
so much I mean frozen aside I will say
one of the coolest things about coming
back to Kingdom Hearts is that there
have been so many new Disney movies
since then to incorporate and to walk
around the worlds of like there was
tangled in there like you pointed out
wreck-it Ralph wreck-it Ralph that's
gonna be exactly wreck-it Ralph you know
is all video game stuff anyway I wonder
if you're gonna get to go to the
Internet because of the second record
Ralph's movie yeah I feel like they're
in a good position to these games are
really successful like Kingdom Hearts is
a beloved game a beloved series now and
I feel like once you do a game like this
you would have to keep expanding it and
keep all the stuff you had before but
yeah I mean this looks like a lot of fun
it looks like there's a good varied
gameplay going on yeah cuz you have
stuff where it's like you on foot with
Donald Duck in the gang and then that
does look fun I mean you know I'm not
the world's biggest frozen person but
the ice stuff does look like fun the
world opened you got Kyrie like for a
brief glimpse at the end they're sitting
next to axel so you know hopefully we'll
get to continue their journey as friends
despite the hopping through various IPs
and one
and there's so many clues about Roxas
returning so oh Jesus more than Roxas is
Richard yeah there's gonna be one of
these every decade just isn't enough
time for games who have changed a whole
lot and just enough time to be a whole
bunch more Disney properties we need to
see in a video it looks like classic
Kingdom parks what you want it to be
which is fun hmm that's why I was so
drawn to it as a kid I think it's
because it wasn't a game you had to take
so seriously yeah it was Disney
characters yeah you had to be tough
bosses and whatnot but it was a fun
adventure
oh yeah well in the ever-changing worlds
and the different kinds of game play
that allows you I mean it is I get why
people love this came so much and
especially like with all the Disney
heads out there like so guys what did
y'all think of the Kingdom Hearts 3
trailer are you excited are you so amped
that there's frozen now hit us up in the
comment box let us know and as always
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell cuz the
subscribe button doesn't do its job
follow Olivia on the instagrams at
forever Tiffany's and check us out on
patreon we got full-length TV show watch
alongs music video reactions a little
bunch of cool stuff over there q and a's
and whatnot love to have you be well
people Cheers